the Met Commissioner must have thought
he'd found some sanctuary when he came
to sham knees as part of his
rehabilitation it had two operations on
his leg was slowly getting back on his
feet suppose Stevenson checked in at the
resort over a five week period in
February and March this year he was
often with his wife lady Linda he made
full use of the rehabilitation
facilities treatments paid for by the
met his room and meals though were paid
by the managing director Stephen / jus a
close family friend he was in a very bad
way and we were happy to help I insisted
that he came he didn't really want to
take my hospitality to that degree but
there's nothing untoward what we really
helped only want to get back to work it
was jus to go back to work in July he
may be in April thanks to champions the
PR man for the resort's was Niall
Wallace former news of the world deputy
editor and arrested this week as part of
the hacking investigation again none of
this confirms any wrongdoing by the Met
Commissioner but it does establish
further links between key individuals on
different sides of the hacking
investigation an investigation his
officers were carrying out I think when
the public starts losing faith in the
police it's all together much more
serious and we really are in you know
some some trouble and that's why I think
it's very important that the Commission
should answer the questions that should
be put to him by the Home Secretary and
answer them very funny the fallout from
the hacking scandal has now got to the
point where labor feel the time is right
for the Murdoch Empire to be cut back
this concentration of power must never
be able to happen again because it was
too mighty for government it was too
mighty for the police and actually it's
odd Miliband and Parliament that has
stopped it in its traffic but there are
suspicions that the whole episode is now
being used to settle scores with the
media I think that politicians would be
wise at the moment not to overreact that
there is a definite feeling of
politicians wanting to if you like get
the run back on on some elements of the
media it's time for I think
harmless and for people to look at these
issues yes seriously bought in a proper
time scale and without hysteria News
International has taken out further
adverts to say sorry and to explain how
they're going to put things right with
questions to on the other side of the
Atlantic 4 News core Rupert Murdoch's
Empire is under unprecedented scrutiny
the apologies may well continue when he
appears to answer questions from MPs in
Westminster on Tuesday Tom Parmenter